okay so this is another way and I think
those clouds are gonna give me
nightmares red and the seizure inducing
flashes that is just like oh my god it's
just like yeah well that was okay that
was actually Jory's big Creed's like the
laughing was it is the kissing the fetus
I can't stand feet I hate feet they they
disgust me you know I'm somebody else I
really like was terrified of feet too
it's just like thought they're gross
just want nothing to do with those feet
should never exist but they did we would
just keep falling over because we
wouldn't be able to put our lakes on
anything well that would be used to it
so it won't be anything different they
should not be seen or heard be free my
friend all right well regardless visit
episode called another way and yeah what
was it Finn and Jake jump off of birds
which is the title card I thought that
was kind of fun yeah and they gig or
Jake gets clown doctors to look after
them and and they're pretty annoying and
Finn aids it I'm wondering if it's like
a Molesworth if it's like a patch Adams
commentary or something like that
cabbage okay okay I got a patch Adams
thing yes that's different what that's
gonna patch Adams thing well no because
he okay one the movie it's done really
bad but in real life you know he would
incorporate like the clowning and
medical health together he'd say that
the more upbeat a positive you were the
faster and better you would get you know
that was a thing which Achin kind of has
been proven you know but in the movie
you just make it look like oh my god
this guy ever came near you I just you
know keep it morphine man come on this
this guy's a pain um but so I'm almost
wondering if that's like a slam or if
it's just like just a fine coincidence I
don't know
but I think it was more just disturbing
yeah anything else and one of them just
like they say the only way to fix their
broken legs is to keep kissing
oven-baked it's the only way it goes
really red and does these constant
flashes like police sirens and she just
laughs and they keep coming back to it
it causes Finn to go insane and he gets
on this big kick about I could always do
it my way I'll find my way and so he
just he's gonna go fine was an ogre
Cyclops Sagi is gonna fire Cyclops that
whose tears are magical and can fix
anything and he comes across all these
people and things I say oh there's only
two ways to go through here you can do
it this way or that way same path the
one path you lose all your hair the
other paths you stink yeah he goes by
weight he goes down the middle and it's
like always a painful pants because
there's like thorns and stuff like that
and then he comes to the river where
these all these plant life keep talking
about like a tree trunk it many tree
trunks Oh true okay tree stump there you
go oh I sort of thought maybe they were
done by the same voice too because
particularly that boys before the river
is sounds very much like tree trunks in
my opinion I don't wait the one with the
path yeah actually that's done by a
famous guy um his name's I only know
miss Neil hamburger he did he did an
album of like great prank phone calls
and he was also I'm talking about band
he was in he was also in a band but I
know because he worked with my Patton
now okay I'm a huge fan of but yeah so
that's who that is that it's not tree
trunks okay and actually the first one
the one with the path yeah I think it's
the witch lawyers yeah it sounded like a
voice I heard before I think so about
like configure but so he's always my way
my way and finally his way he gets like
this little guy's wife injured it feels
bad and then comes across the Cyclops
who starts beating him up
you know just mistaking why
there but then Finn uses his way that
time and it works a gets the Cyclops to
cry and he rips his head off and then
just like horses sleep yeah and like
forces the tears on everybody he comes
across it makes everything there even a
sandwich which you didn't even know was
sick is that way my god great and then
he comes back and the clowns kiss the
Cyclops and all look good classic tale I
mean it was my again it's erm feels
kinda like a return to form to like the
like the first season a little bit
especially with that laughing clown
oh that mess sandwich bits the sandwich
bit yes you very much even the ending
like you know where he's like yeah you
know you know what that's okay Jake just
gets these big guys here it sparkling
cool it like that's it you know I'm very
brand offending um and I think that
saying because it's not like I'm an old
disappoint with the direction it's going
I'm not it's just it's kind of cool when
you have something that's just as random
as it used to be well I apologize uh
comments people just remember when I
talked about the executive balls yeah
they they actually said what it was in
the comments and I completely forgot
what the heck they are cradle what is it
Newton's Cradle remember I was seeing
that's kind of what it was you have this
bizarre one and then it kind of swings
back to a serious one then swings back I
think we're finally getting some of the
bizarre once again yeah um and uh but it
was funny and I like how I kind of like
how a lot I think it says before like a
lot of extremes rarely kind of pay off
like everything is always this and this
is always that that's rarely you know is
the case but so I sort of like that he's
doing this extreme it didn't pay off but
it also didn't show like it's not that
it'll never work cuz he tries it his way
later he says ah my way can sometimes
work and it's yeah I think it's a good
last day it's you know it's just it it
can work just not all the time or even
majority that you just take it as it
goes everyone does have their own way
yeah so is this so I got like that um
and yeah I'm trying to think of what
else those just those clowns are gonna
give me nightmares
can't they get to my dad well what about
the one the one clown that was blowing
bubble yeah budding the bubbles of love
no one's voice - you want me to stop
that uh there's one clown okay even more
than the one that's laughing with the
red background and stuff the head these
eyes that were just like stretched out
again for thin that was really creepy
those clowns are scary I hope they never
come back I'll keep my mouth shut on
that not great well what do you think of
it yeah like oh this is the first time I
saw it I was kind of like eh but this is
one episode where the more I've watched
it the more I kind of like really enjoy
it um because I don't know like I said
for some shadows like yeah but like I
love the shrub the disc is consistently
berating Finn even as they're running
through there and he's using a missus
ban and everything's like we're all he
have what are you idiot it's oh you know
wow that the one thing I forgot to make
I thought was really funny is you know
he he throws the the boys across and
it's a cross and then he tries to skip
himself I love like I thought that that
was really funny um but no I just I just
the more I watch it the more I love it
and I'm really glad and this one they
brought back his auto-tuned singing
things yeah that's where I disappeared
for a while - yeah I got that back it
does kind of like come and go which I
like that they haven't forgotten about
it that it does still exist but it was
nice to kind of hear and then also
seeing the trees in the background just
kind of like going like all sad as he's
singing these songs were just like oh I
didn't even know and the design of the
Cyclops himself were one legis like all
just like straight up like a tree cuz he
has a bunch of little trees but it was
like
all routes it's pretty neat I don't know
yeah the kind of like the the trees on
him and said well I like that he was
actually on the Cyclops the whole time
you know when he gets up the eye opens
up that's like the one thing from Dragon
heart I know it's a weird reference but
it's like the one seen that that was a
cool scene where like this guy sits on
when he thinks it's a rock and he turned
it turns out the head of a drag you just
know cuz this eye opens up and it's like
it's just like the one thing I remember
I'm like okay that's cool so I love any
show or movie that could just show so
you think it's something else that you
just see an eye open up you're like oh
it's the one memorable scene okay
aside from Sean Connery Oh see now
you're bringing up a no and you said
it's the one memorable scene except for
this also okay and one memorable scenes
with Sean Connery's non-pc booming voice
coming out this gigantic dragon which
slowly dispatch y.base oh that's not
that's not the beast I was talking about
but the movie would be better I've never
seen guys stop giving me these false
names it's terrible but it's funny well
it's both pretty funny
I said I'm watching her no because
you're talking about that one done I'm
gonna get the name wrong I apologize
man straight story straight story oh
that's great that's how you said though
what about the other one oh that's great
except for you always have an except for
you know you'll just have to do it your
way
it's the only way